Bugün size çok güzel haberler
vereceğim industry 4.0 şimdi Ali Bey'den
dinledik E iş 3
devrimi
burada kaçınız çalıştığı işten
memnun güzel hiç fena değil peki yanında
bazıları firma olarak geldiğini
biliyorum
yanınızda eksperler ekibi
nerede
peki hayatınızın sonuna
kadar bu işi yapmayı planlıyor
musunuz güzel yine bazıları var ama
Eller azaldı Peki size kendi
kariyerinizi kendinizin çizebileceği ve
her şeyin esnek olduğu bir geleceğin
mümkün olduğunu söylesem ne düşünürdünüz
şimdi size onim devriminden bahsedeceğim
Ama anlatacaklarım pek çoğunu Ali Bey
anlattı Onun için çocukluğumdan
başlayacağım Adana'da
doğdum Adana e
Tarsus'ta liseyi okudum üniversiteye
İstanbul'a geldim
daha
sonra üniversiteyi bitirdiğimde ne
yapacağım la ilgili hiçbir fikrim
olmadığının farkına vardım ve korku
içindeydim bu korku beni bir şekilde
Hindistan'a
götürdü Hindistan'da uzun seneler kaldım
farklı işler yaptım
Eee yaptığım ikinci İş
aslında
dünyada bir değişim olduğunu fark etmemi
sağladı çalıştığım ilk firma
Hindistan'da ikinci firma daha doğrusu
Hindistan'da Amerika'da ve Avrupa'da
olan işleri alıp orada binlerce kişi ve
bunlar bahsettiğim işler aynı
zamanda yatırım bankalarının veyahut da
en ünlü danışmanlık firmalarının
işlerini Hindistan Şili Çin gibi
ülkelerde yapıyorlardı
ve 1000 kişilik 2000 kişilik firmalar
A'dan Z'ye olmasa da en ünlü yatırım
bankalarının işini A'dan belki u'ya ya
da x'e kadar
yapıyorduk
ve bu değişim
Aslında büyük bir değişimin habercisiydi
bundan 202 yıl önce başlayan internetle
gelen devrimin iş gücüne yansımasının
habercisi Hindistan'dan sonra firma beni
Şili'ye gönder verdi ve şidde bana gelen
ilk proje bir on demand firmayı
araştırmam üzerineydi
airbnb Otelcilik endüstrisini
araştırırken bu firmanın e nasıl
olduğunu sordular bundan 67 sene önceydi
ve airbnb araştırdım büyülendim her şey
çok farklıydı kaynaklar esnek olarak
kullanılıyordu bütünsel birlikte
kullanılıyordu firma çok hızlı büyüyordu
ve bu firma Aslında ilk Bir senesi
yatırım alamamıştı
Çünkü yatırımcılar bu firmaya
inanmıyordu olayın Özünde Güven vardı
insanlar Başka insanlara evini kiralar
mı bu kaynaklar ortak kullanılır mı bir
senesinde 20.000 dolar aldıktan sonra Şu
an itibariyle yaklaşık 4,5 milyar
dolarlık yatırımı olan bu sene halkı
olacak ve 190 ülkede 1 milyon kişiye ev
kiralayan bir firma
airbnb çok
etkilendim ve ondan sonra Türkiye'ye
bunun iş gücü üzerine yansımasını
düşürerek Türkiye'ye geldim ve expertera
kurduk expertera aslında şu anda çok en
üst düzey uzmanların çalıştığı ve
kendilerinin saatlik günlük ve proje
bazlı danışmanlar yaptığı Türkiye'den ve
dünyanın her yerinden uzmanların
çalışabildiği ve firmaların bu
uzmanlarla esnek çalışabildiği bir
platform ve on demand Devriminin bir
habercisi Çünkü onent devrimi sadece
airbnb ve Uber değil onent devrimi ile
ulaşım Finans tüketim ürünleri mekan
bireysel hizmetler Bundan 20 sene önce
Ben 20 sene aynı evde kaldım Türkiye'de
Beşiktaş'ta ve Eee o zaman taşınırken
bir kahvehaneye girip nerede burada
taşımacı var mı derken şu anda eee bir
site yazıyorum ve sabah taşımacılar evde
oluyor böyle bir farktan bahsediyorum
ekonomi değişime Aslında hepsini buradan
yönetebiliyor ve iş gücü de artık buraya
doğru geçiyor Şimdi bunu zaten az önce
çok detaylı dinledik
ama burada burada çok önemli bir değişim
var şu anda bulunduğumuz nokta tam
olarak Sanayi
ekonomisinden bilgi ekonomisine doğru
yani internetle birlikte değişen bilgi
ekonomisine doğru bir geçişte ve bu
geçiş Bütün her şeyin değişmesi demek şu
ana kadar 202 sene önce olan bu Devrim
ve Oradan da Sanayi 40'lara giden
devrimin iş gücüne olan yansımasını
kısmen gördük ama
artık Bu demek değil ki aynı şekilde
çalışacağız işte burada iş 3-0 devrimi
devreye giriyor iş 1.0 da sanayi devrimi
ile birlikte herkes tarım devriminden
çıktı E tarlalarından çıktılar veyahut
da Demir atölyesinden çıktılar firmalara
girdiler firmalar herkes firmada
çalışıyordu iş 2.0 La birlikte Aslında
daha kontrat bazlı çalışmaya başlayan ve
son 200 yıldır iş 1-0 devam ederken
1900'lerin ik yarısında özellikle iş 2-0
biraz daha öne çıkmaya başladı ve
kontrat bazlı çalışma ortaya çıkmaya
başladı daha sonra son 10 senelik bir
gelişme bütün bunları altüst etti iş 3.0
devrimi platformlar Yani artık
insanların on demand bir şekilde
çalışmaya başladığı ve firmaların bu iş
gücüne istediği kadar ve istediği
zamanda kendi ihtiyacı kadar
uzanabildiğin
buna Bulut iş gücü veyahut da yakasız
çalışma da diyorum ne kadar büyük dersek
2000 25
itibariyle yetenek platformlarında
yapılacak iş hacminin 2.7 trilyon
dolarlık ve bu sadece ilk adımı olarak
bu arada değerlendiriliyor ve 540 milyon
kişinin yetenek platformlarında
çalışması bekleniyor bundan 8 sene
içinde Türkiye için bu ne kadar
büyük yine 2025 yılında 800.000 kişi ve
40 milyar doların üstünde bir değişim
Yani on kariyerler imizi planlamaya
düşünmeye başlamamız fayda var Nasıl bir
hızda dersek
Size yine bir grafik göstereyim bu
online iş gücü endeksi grafiği ve son
bir senedir tutuluyor bütün bu
değişimler o kadar yeni ki bütün çoğu
istatistik zaten son 2 senenin
istatistiği son çok fazla ben
kariyerimin ilk yıllarında da trader
yaptım çok grafik analiz ettim herhalde
bu grafiğin çok fazla bir analize
ihtiyacı yok diye düşünüyorum sadece son
2 aydaki değişim % 30'un üstünde 10 10
di gücü platformları üstündeki çalışma
peki bunun bizim için anlamı nedir
geleceğin iş gücünde bir yetenek havuzı
artık Coğrafyayla sınırlı değil artık
sadece yerel çalışanlara erişimle
olmuyor yani gelin şurada bir ekip
kuralım ve bir şeyler yapalım değil
artık Global yetenek havuzuyla
çalışabiliyor bizim şu anda ekspert
olarak Eee bazı dizayner varımız Eee
Güney Amerika'da bazı Eee developerlar
mız apayrı lokasyonlarda ama biz hala
bir yandan burada çalışıyoruz şu anda
bizle çalışan firmalar kendi on demand
yönetim kurullarını dahi kurabiliyor ve
dünyanın çeşitli yerlerinde Amerika'da
Avrupa'da Çin'de bu iş gücünü
yönetebiliyor kimi Uzmanlar buraya
geliyor Kimisi uzaktan çalışıyor ve bu
şekilde geleceğin iş gücü işliyor 2
artık sürekli sözleşmeler ve tek bir
şirket için çalışma değil çalışanlar pek
çok farklı müşteriyle farklı projelerde
çalışabiliyorlar Yani bir yere girdim
belirli bir iş verildi ve ben sadece onu
yapıyorum değil çok farklı müşteriyi de
kendi istediğimiz tipte farklı
projelerde
çalışabiliyor 3 ofis saatlerinde Bu
ödemeler Nasıl para kazanıyoruz artık
ofis saatlerinde bulunup her ay başı
maaş aldığımız bir çalışma yöntemi değil
esnek çalışma saatleri E Günlük ya da
saatlik eee bir şekilde çalışma ve sonuç
bazlı
Eee ödüllendirme sistemler
üzerine gelişen bir model Eee dördüncüsü
geleceğin iş gücünde bilgi çok daha açık
ve çok daha paylaşımcı git gide oluyor
zaten ve eskisi gibi bir firma içinde
kalan bilgiler değil En iyi
uygulamaların daha paylaşıldığı bir e
döneme giriyoruz ve artık uzun vadeli
firmalar uzun vadeli ve 5 senelik belki
1900'ler Deek gibi 5 senelik planlar 10
senelik planlar değil çok daha dinamik
hızlı deneysel yöntemlerle sprintler
sürekli öğrenmeler kendini yapan Eee ve
yaşayan planlar üreten artık anlık
planlar değil yaşayan planlar üreten Eee
yapılar ve organizasyonlardan
bahsediyoruz altıncısı ve belki de en
önemlisi sabit rollere dayalı hiyerarşik
yapılarda değil esnek akışkan dinamik
görevler roller ve ekipler yani şu andan
itibaren artık E çok daha belki mikro
işler alacağız E bir anda ekipler bir
araya geliyorlar dağılıyorlar e Bulut iş
gücünden firmalar kendi işlerini çekiyor
eski büyüklükte değil ve biliyorsunuz
kurumsal yapılar daha hantal diye
biliniyor daha küçük yapılarda daha
esnek hızlı çok daha inovasyona açık
gelişime açık Eee yapılarda gelişen
sistemler Bunlar Çünkü artık o kadar
hızlı değişiyor ve gelişiyor ki e
organizasyon yapıları bu hıza inovasyon
anlamında ayak uydurması Ancak bu
metotla mümkün Şimdi burada sorgulamamız
gereken nokta şu geldiğimiz
yerde sadece eskiye bakarak şu ana kadar
çoğunlukta bu beni şaşırtan kısmı eskiye
bakarak karar alıyoruz ama müthiş
değişimler oluyor ve burada Aynı zamanda
da beni çok heyecanlandıran bölümleri e
devreye giriyor aynı zamanda size
söyleyeceğim iyi haberler artık
kararlarımızı geçmiş ve eskideki kariyer
ve kariyer basamakları değil farklı
şekilde ileriye doğru bakarak bu
kararlarımızı almamız gerekiyor Nasıl
bir Artık iş ve kariyerler imizi iş ve
kariyer olarak değil Finans ik vesaire
olarak değil kendi adına çözülecek
problemleri belirleyerek kendi adına
çözülecek problemler her şey
olabilir endüstri 40'ı bir ülkede
oturtmak olabilir veyahut da kambur ve
eğik durma yerine daha dik durmayı
düzenlemek olabilir ama kendi adına
çözülecek problemleri
belirlemek ve artık onun üzerine
çalışmak geleceğin belirleyici etmeni iş
gücü adına
ikincisi gerekli iş yeteneklerini
öğrenmek lazım İş yetenekleri artık çok
farklı bakın birkaç tane haber
Üniversitede öğreneceğiniz 4 sene ve çok
iyi bir üniversitede olacağınızı
varsayarsak yine dun bir raporuna göre
söyleyeceğim ünitede öğreneceğiniz 4
senede öğrenecekleriniz 5 sene içinde
artık Eee tedavülden
kalkıyor Yani onun için kendinizi
sürekli yenilemeniz ve değiştirmeniz
gerekiyor ve bu yenilik ve değiştirmeyi
Artık yeni dönem yeteneklere göre ve
çözülecek ve farklı sektörlere farklı
fonksiyonlara adapte edilebilir
yeteneklerle yapmamız lazım geleceğin iş
yetenekleri bu Future institute
yayınladığı bunlara daha Detay
bakabilirsiniz
dünyadaki farklı disruption dalgaları ve
ona göre oluşturulacak yetenekler ki
burada aslında şu anda çok çok güzel
Türkiye'de de okullar açılıyor Maker
hareketinden bahsettik Az önce
kodlamadan bahsettik yani bunları artık
çok Daha yaratıcı yapıcı bir şekilde
kullanabileceğimiz yetenekleri edinmemiz
gerekiyor öğrenme şekerimizi
değiştirmemiz gerekiyor ve
3 kendimizi tanımak kişisel bilincimizi
arttırmak Yani artık geldiğimiz nokta
Ali Rıza Bey'in söylediğini görüyorum ve
arttırıyorum kas gücü ve beyin Evet kas
gücü ve beyini yaptık Eee Binlerce yıl
boyunca çalıştık on binlerce yıl boyunca
Daha doğrusu ve bir yere geldik artık
öyle bir noktaya geldik ki bütün
yaptıklarımızı robotlara devrettik ve
şimdi bir kısmını yapay zekaya da
devrediyoruz Peki daha Ötesinde ne
olacak yani biz o zaman daha neler
yapacağız işte burada
kendimizi tanımaya başlamamız gerekiyor
kişisel bilincimizi arttırmamız
gerekiyor ve buna göre kendi
yolculuğumuza çıkıp Belki de Hindistan'a
doğru atacağınız veyahut da kendi ne
yapmak istiyorsanız atacağınız farklı
adımlar artık belki de Günün Sonunda şu
anda aynı expertera da olduğu gibi
farklı hayallerin birleştiği ve aynı
zamanda tamamen yeni dönem iş gücünün
oturtulduğu bir bir hikayeye doğru
gidebilir Onun için artık ne yapmamız
gerekiyor
Eee kendimizin en iyi tohumları ekmem
gerekiyor geçmiş hiç değişmeyecek diye
ve hep aynı şekilde bugüne kadar nasıl
böyle gelmiş böyle gidecek Eee yanılgıs
kurtulmamız lazım Çünkü böyle gelmiş
böyle gidecek dediğimiz Az önce gördük
şu anda yeni döneme doğru geçiyoruz ve
bu dönemi kendimiz hep beraber inşa
edeceğiz ve bunun için de kendimizden
başlamamız gerekiyor ve bu değişimi hep
birlikte yaratmamız gerekiyor ve burada
e bakın bir örnek vereceğim bunu geçen
hafta okudum geçtiğimiz hafta dünya 80
yıl yaşayan bir insan hayatı gibi
düşünürsek şu anda 40 yaşında İnsanoğlu
8 saat önce Afrika'dan çıkmış ve son
yarım saatini biliyoruz Ve bazen de
Diyoruz ki son yarım saat nasıl geçtiyse
geri kalan 40 senede öyle geçecek ama
öyle değil yani şu anda elimize alıp
güzel tohumları ekmem gerekiyor bazı
gördüğümüz Eee ve iyi olduğunu
düşündüklerimizi ekmem gerekiyor
geleceği beraber inşa etmemiz gerekiyor
kendimizden başlamamız gerekiyor
Eee bu şeyle de yarın anneler günü bütün
annelerin de Anneler gününü kutlarım Çok
teşekkürler
sağ